haha the Joe Rogan experience so it's
either one of two things you either
pivot find something you're good at and
go that direction or if you're willing
to put any effort figure out how to get
better at what you're not good at right
and then and then apply those things now
it's gonna be hard it's gonna suck you
still may not even get to the same level
or degree as somebody else who's
naturally talented in it in that sense
but what's the alternative [ __ ] about
it and like you said complain complain
complain when I see people particularly
this happens when you see people who are
not very good commenting on people who
are successful they start saying this is
one of the reasons why I could never
make it because the people that made
their sellouts or their this or their
that like okay is that you know who
doesn't leave comments like that winners
this is so true that's the factor that's
the [ __ ] you Dave Chappelle is not going
on [ __ ] Twitter talking [ __ ] about
people this is that's the facts the
people who are really successful are the
ones who are analyzing themselves
looking at their own work and keep
moving doesn't mean you don't fail
doesn't mean you know [ __ ] you don't
make mistakes and they think the
difference though is you do it publicly
yeah you mess up publicly oh yeah and
that's a lot to take in and like even
like when I went on when I was on them
and when I was on Bill Martin I was on a
roundtable I didn't think I did a good
job
I don't it's [ __ ] almost impossible to
do a good job in that goddamn Roundtable
it was it was probably my worst showings
now for reasons that I think I went into
it thinking I could I went into it like
a lawyer
I thought I can go on reason and maybe
understand
I was out class because they had a great
command of using emotion and clapping
well there's that yeah they're teachers
[Applause]
yeah I don't think it's a good way to
communicate and I said it was a bill on
the show he's trying to talk me into
doing the show and I think I agreed to
it but then I found ways to get out of
it this is why man talking one-on-one is
hard enough like you have a thought
sometimes you're expanding and I have a
thought and I'm holding on to it yeah
but then you keep talking and I don't
know when to get it in there
lose it now when there's three other
[ __ ] people and they're all trying to
get sound bites they're hoping are gonna
be on YouTube it's all performative it
is a lot of it a lot of its performative
and then on top of it it really is
performative because there's a [ __ ]
audience yeah right yeah and they're all
liberal and they're all clapping and
cheering and they're all and which they
should be they're his fans of times I
would it to be like I'd make a point and
I'm like really it's one thing to
perform if you're doing stand-up or
singing a song or something like that in
front of a large crowd that's one thing
yeah but like having conversations in
front of crowds it's like weird animal
man weird added element and you're
you're appealing to others to chime in
and reinforce your your thoughts yeah no
you're absolutely right now I will
forever ever ever be grateful that he
gave me the opportunity to go into that
lines then because it's a place that I
think a lot of pro-gun people haven't
been able to get to hopefully I
communicated in a manner that was that
resonated with a lot of people in the
same same way here it's I'd be lying if
I said I did not value the ability to
have the for the time being within this
two-hour three-hour space to have access
to your audience at the same time
because I I don't understand well hi I
mean I understand why but I'm just
passionate about this in a way that
sometimes even I have a hard time
articulating and so when I see all of
these new people because I know your
audience is very vast like I have a base
there was a base of my audience right
the gun people and a lot of them very
conservative and with your audience it
gives me the ability to speak to a wider
gap of people who would otherwise never
even look in my direction because of
what I talked about and so it in aren't
that many platforms that are available
right now that are willing to open their
doors to the opposite perspective
because you got it you made me a smart
guy you know this this puts you in a
very peculiar situation you you can end
up looking really bad because you're
literally confronting and testing out
all of your ideas
right in front of your audience that
thinks you know everything right and so
many people aren't willing to do that
because they were worried about looking
bad which is why I get mad props to Bill
Maher as well
because there aren't a mini platform
most people just want to sit in their
echo chambers right yell at the audience
and say all right right yeah so I have a
hard pressed to think about any other
type of platforms that may have a
different perspective that would let me
come on like this and that's just me
being honest well I think it's important
to talk to people that have all sorts of
different ideas you know the thing
there's a thing going on today where
people talk about giving someone a
platform you shouldn't be giving them
access to your platform I'm like well
what the [ __ ] is the purpose of a
platform if it's not to test out ideas
if it's not like if you want to talk to
someone I mean I'm not talking about
someone like who's in the KKK yeah a
minutes but talking to people that have
controversial viewpoints one of the best
ways to sort those viewpoints out is to
challenge them there and in fact there's
a lot of people that would support a lot
of there's people that have had on where
I've confronted them on their ideas and
it they lost a lot of fans because it
meant because these ideas now fall apart
under scrutiny yeah under someone who
could talk to you for long periods of
time and just start going okay well why
do you think that yeah and then they say
this and that and then you go but
where's that coming from
yeah and then they see this and then as
you get deeper and deeper you get to the
basement and you go oh this is a [ __ ]
there's nothing in here
[Applause]